MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Talks at
Google in Cambridge, Mass.
Today it's my enormous
pleasure to welcome
Nick Hornby to Google.
Wow.
Nick, welcome.
NICK HORNBY: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So great
to have you here.
I suspect your reputation and
what you're known for in the UK
is probably a little
different from how
you're known in the US.
Just do a quick survey here.
How many people here have seen
movies made from one or more
of Nick's books?
Good representation.
How many people have read
one or more of Nick's novels?
Excellent representation.
Very good.
How many people have read
Nick's music criticism
in "The New Yorker"?
Yep.
Hands.
Excellent.
How many people have
read Nick's book reviews
either in "The Believer"
or in collections
that have been published?
All right.
Wow.
OK.
I might have misspoken.
Very, very
well-represented here.
How many people know
that in addition
to being the author of the
things we just mentioned,
Nick is also a screenwriter?
How many people--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Yes, it is.
NICK HORNBY: I'm
never going to speak.
MALE SPEAKER: With PERF coming
up in just a few months,
this will be noted.
Sorry.
OK.
So actually, quite
well-known in the US.
So the point being that you are
a man and author of many parts,
certainly best
known here, I think,
for the novels and the movies
that have been made from them,
but certainly also
well-represented
in the nonfiction area as well.
And--
NICK HORNBY: Well,
it's interesting,
because in some ways, I
prefer my American career
to my British career,
because everything in the UK
is seen through the prism of
my first book, which was "Fever
Pitch," and because I
wrote about football,
then that was it.
I was a football writer forever.
And of course, things
like "The Believer,"
they're only
published here anyway.
The magazine doesn't
really get read in the US.
And I suppose recently, the
screenplay stuff-- people
saw "An Education" in the UK.
They haven't seen "Wild" really.
It just came out last week.
So I probably have more of
a mix in the US than the UK.
MALE SPEAKER: Interesting.
So you've sort of been
typecast as a football writer?
NICK HORNBY: Yes.
I mean, I've only written
one football book,
and it was 20 years
ago, but I think
there's something about
writing about sport that
means that you are
ghettoized forever.
Doesn't matter what I write.
From now on, I will
always be a sports writer.
It's OK, because I
don't actually do it,
so they could ghettoize
me all they like.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
OK, well.
And actually the next question,
of course, here in the States,
we just had one of our biggest
annual sporting events,
which is the Super Bowl.
And of course, as you were
just talking about your career
started off with "Fever
Pitch," which by the way,
is on my list of one of the
top five titles of all time.
Such a great concept.
So not to ghettoize
you further, but if we
had to start off by talking
about sports, one thing that
struck me, I've never
lived in the UK,
but just from reading
about it, well,
Americans can be
great sports fans.
It's always seemed to me that
just from reading about it
that there's something
very different in the UK
that British-- maybe
obsession is putting it
too strongly, maybe not-- but
the bond between UK soccer
fans in their
teens is so strong,
a lifelong thing, as
you can attest to,
that seems to be entirely
different from what
we have in the US.
Is that something
you've noticed as well?
NICK HORNBY: Yes.
I think that Americans
obviously love sports.
But I think there's
much more enjoyment
of sport as an event in the US.
And there are a couple
of explanations, I think.
One is that baseball,
you can't see
every game of the
baseball season.
And even if you're
a big baseball fan,
you don't go to
all the home games.
No one has a life,
pretty much, that
can accommodate every single
home game in a baseball season,
and the away games are
too far away, whereas it's
routine in the UK never to miss
a home game of your football
team.
And a significant
subsection of those people
never miss an away game either.
In person, I mean, actually
sitting in the stadiums.
And that's partly because
of the length of the season.
That elite season is 38
games, so it's conceivable
that you can go to all of those.
And the size of the
country, of course,
as well, that means
that there's no away
game you can go to where you
can't get back that night.
And I do think that makes
for a different culture.
And also, of course, I think
probably more true in America,
but lots of people don't live in
the cities where they grew up.
There's more freedom of
movement, as it were,
in the US.
So I think that there is
possibly a greater intensity.
An American football
season is really short,
and it would be hard to
base your life around that.
The baseball season's too long.
And the other thing is that
you are genuinely interested,
I think, as a population,
in more than one sport.
And so people spread themselves
over, certainly over baseball,
football, maybe
hockey, basketball,
whereas I'd say over the
last 20 years, football--
we have become one
sport in the UK.
It used to be
football and cricket,
but cricket has become much more
of a minority sport probably
since Rupert Murdoch's
television money.
So we're very, very intense
about the football and not
much else.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
I had no idea cricked had
been sort of deprecated.
NICK HORNBY: Well,
cricket's difficult,
because it is a game
that lasts for five days.
And usually at the
end of the five days,
it's a draw, because actually,
five days isn't long enough.
But they figure they can't
go on longer than five days,
but you can't bowl a team out
twice in five days, basically.
So I'd say about
half the games end
in a draw, and the equivalent,
the international games are
big, especially when
England play Australia.
And then it's sold
out crowds of 30,000,
and they play five times over
the course of the summer.
And there is a sense of
that is something happening,
and people are watching.
But the club games
are between counties,
so Kent will play against
Somerset over five days
during the week, during the day.
So it's usually in front of
crowds of 20 or 30 people.
And it's kind of hard to
get excited about that,
whereas football is a
working person's sport.
They play outside of
work hours one evening
during the week
and then weekend,
so it's possible
to see everything.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
Of course, here in
Boston, as you may know,
our local billionaire, John
Henry, owns Liverpool FC.
I hope that doesn't upset
you as an Arsenal fan.
NICK HORNBY: But Stan
Kroenke owns Arsenal,
who's an American
who owns-- well,
he's-- I think he's a-- does
anyone know what Stan Kroenke
owns?
It's a couple of sports
teams here in America,
and I think his wife
owns Walmart as well.
So there's almost
no English club
that's owned by-- no big English
club is owned by English people
anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Is that a fairly
recent phenomenon?
NICK HORNBY: Yep.
Again, since, pretty much
since the Murdoch money.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That name keeps coming up.
NICK HORNBY: It
does keep coming up.
We have a big problem
now with English sport,
because it's become
uncompetitive, the football.
I think most people feel
that only two teams can
win the championship
in England, and they're
both-- one's owned
by an oligarch,
and one's owned by a sheik,
and their budgets are
more or less unlimited,
and this year, one of them
will finish first, and the
other one will finish second.
Last year, it was
the other way around.
And it's hard to
get really excited.
Arsenal can't win
a championship.
Liverpool can't
win a championship,
unless something changes.
They're trying to alter the
laws so that these clubs have
to be run as a business,
meaning that you can't spend
an infinite amount without
bringing anything back in.
But they always have all
kinds of ways around it,
and it's a little bit
depressing at the moment.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
Absolutely.
NICK HORNBY: When you've
got lots of rich people
who own sporting clubs,
but you've got draft picks,
and you've got salary caps, and
you've got all sorts of things
that actually we can't
do, because we have
the disadvantage of playing a
game that the rest of the world
plays, whereas America
only plays American sports.
MALE SPEAKER: That's true.
I can never get over the fact
that beach volleyball became
an Olympic sport, so that's--
NICK HORNBY: There's
a very funny episode
of "30 Rock" where
one of the characters
discovers that most of
the sports he was watching
at the Summer Olympics were
actually staged by a network
and didn't really
exist out in the world,
but had been invented
to give Americans
medals at the Olympics.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
Like beach volleyball.
NICK HORNBY: Like
beach volleyball.
MALE SPEAKER: So switching
from sports to writing,
you wrote the screenplay
for the British version
of "Fever Pitch."
I do want to get back
to screenwriting later
in the conversation.
Just have to ask
you, having written
a screenplay for
the British version,
what did you think of
the American version?
NICK HORNBY: Well--
MALE SPEAKER: I
have my own opinion.
I didn't want to ask
a leading question.
NICK HORNBY: Well, first
of all, I completely
understood why it
happened, because it's
impossible to have
the same connection
with an American soccer club.
The clubs just haven't
existed for long enough,
and it's not rooted
enough in the culture yet,
so the idea of somebody
who's a grown man
having had an unbroken
relationship with a soccer team
since he was a kid-- that
can't happen in the US.
It had to be
another sport, and I
mean there's a very funny story,
which I'm sure some of you
are aware of with that movie,
which was that they chose
the Boston Red Sox, because they
wanted a team that never won.
And it's a very rare
example of Americans
taking a triumphalist
British film,
and turning it
into something kind
of miserable and depressing.
And so the script was
written about a guy who
supports the Red Sox
and loves the Red Sox,
and they break his
heart every single year.
And they started making
this movie in July.
And then as it got to August,
they started to joke about,
yeah, wouldn't it just be
typical if this was the year?
And then the Red
Sox won the pennant,
and then they got
to the World Series,
and then they realized
they were going
to have to rewrite
the end of the movie.
And they did this as the
Red Sox were winning it,
which is how come Drew
Barrymore and Jimmy Fallon were
on the field for the
last shots of the movie,
with permission from the club.
So all that was kind of
incredible that it happened,
and those shots were incredible
at the end of the film.
It was much more a kind of
mainstream romantic comedy
than, certainly, the book was
and than the English movie was.
I think that it was more about
Drew Barrymore, the movie,
and her character than sport.
So I slightly regretted that
it had become that thing.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I'm not surprised.
"High Fidelity," also
on my top five titles.
But just so you know,
the top five titles
do have at least one Nick
Hornby entry, HMS Pinafore
[INAUDIBLE].
NICK HORNBY: I'm always
in a list with that.
MALE SPEAKER: I know.
How does this keep
happening to you?
NICK HORNBY: Haunted by Gilbert
and Sullivan my entire life.
MALE SPEAKER: That,
plus football, right?
So your first novel, probably
your first transatlantic
success, I would guess.
To me, it seemed that John
Cusack completely got the book.
I was really astonished
by the movie.
I thought it was an
extraordinary adaptation,
despite the change of scenery.
How did you feel about it?
NICK HORNBY: I loved it.
I loved the whole process of it.
I mean, my relationship with
the books and the movies,
when I adapted
"Fever Pitch," I was
whatever I was-- 35 years old
when I began to adapt to it.
I hadn't written a novel.
I didn't know whether
anyone would ever ask again,
whether anyone would want to
adapt one of my books again,
whether I'd ever be asked
to adapt it myself again,
and I had a family,
new baby, I was
in no position to
turn down work.
So when somebody, a producer
came to me and said,
we want to make a movie
out of "Fever Pitch,"
and we want you to try
to do the adaptation,
I didn't think
about it, because I
had a freelance mentality
where I thought,
someone's offering to
pay me to do something.
I'd better do it.
And after I'd done it, and other
books started to be adapted,
I thought, I don't want to
ever adapt my own work again.
I want to move on.
I want to do the next thing.
It's two, three years of
work, a book, and then
you get to the end of
it, and someone says,
we want you to take most
of it out, and write it
in a different form.
Your spirit does-- I find
the spirits lower a bit
with the prospect of that.
So when it came time
to "High Fidelity,"
I said I don't want
to do it myself.
And I was surprised
when they said
we want to set it in the US.
But when I talked to John,
and he's with these two guys
called [? DV ?] and Steve,
and it's kind of sweet.
They'd all grown up in Chicago.
They'd grown up together.
They're all the same age,
two writers and John.
And they thought the
book was about them.
It was their relationship
with music, their relationship
with women, and
of course, that's
what you want someone
to feel if they're
going to adapt your book, and
they changed it so cleverly,
because they changed the frame
of reference for the music,
because they were
younger than me,
so the references
were different.
They weren't the
same as in the book.
The feeling was the same.
There were some very specific
references to Chicago in there.
The Chicago Reader and
some of the clubs, and I
just thought it was done in
a really, really intelligent
and loving way.
And then grumpy
old Stephen Frears
from England was the
director to kind of oversee,
knew what I was talking
about with the book
and knew what they were
talking about with America.
And it was just all a really
kind of happy experience.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, that's great.
I have to say, one of the
key parts of the movie for me
was the casting of Laura.
Reading the book,
for whatever reason,
I couldn't get a really
clear mental image of her,
but as soon as the Danish
actress, whose name I can never
remember or pronounce, came
on screen, I said, wow.
That's Laura.
That's her.
I mean, how did you feel
about the casting overall?
NICK HORNBY: The casting of Rob?
MALE SPEAKER: Or anybody.
NICK HORNBY: Or anybody.
Well, I think that one
of the things that's
wrong with "High
Fidelity" as a book
is that I was scared
to write women.
It was my first novel, and
I knew who the guy was,
and I sort of knew
who the girl was,
but she's-- I think she's
too good in the book.
She's just there as an adult
who's everything that Rob
isn't.
And she didn't have, I think,
enough quirks or reality
to her.
And as my career
has gone on, I felt
more confident to write about
women who messed up in some way
or annoying or bad or
something, but that first novel,
I would say it's a
floor in the book.
So when you say you can't
get a clear mental image,
I'm really not surprised.
And it's a slightly thankless
role in the movie, as well.
She's great, Iben,
but it's John's movie,
and I think that was the last
time I let myself do that.
I thought, from
now on, the women
have to be a lot realer
than they are in this.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
OK.
NICK HORNBY: One
thing that was really
amazing about the movie--
when you're writing a book,
you can obviously have
a character do anything,
because it's fiction, and the
character of Barry in the book
is kind of this annoying,
obnoxious, quite funny, record
store guy, who turns out
to have a great voice.
And you can write
this in a novel.
You can write
anything, and when I
was talking to the guys about
the movie, I said, oh, yeah.
And then you've
got this character.
And they said, we
know who that is.
And I said, what?
You know an actor
who can do that?
They said, yeah, we know
an actor who can do it.
And they knew Jack Black from
kind of alternative comedy,
and he'd not done a comic
role in his movie career,
and that was his first.
That was absolutely
his breakout role,
and I couldn't believe that they
knew the person who I fondly
imagined would only exist
on the pages of a book.
It was very clever casting.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Sort of an iconic role.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah, completely.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
And pairing him off with
Todd Louiso as a sad sack,
and the store was brilliant.
NICK HORNBY: Yes.
The casting is great.
And there's always-- I
have a bit of sadness.
There's a scene in the book that
people quite often ask about,
because they say, why
wasn't that in the movie?
And there's a scene
in the book where
Rob is called to
a woman's house,
and she's selling off her
husband's record collection
for no money, because she
wants to get back at him,
and he has the most amazing
record collection in the world.
And Rob Is so tortured by being
offered it for cheap that he
walks out on it
and won't buy it.
And they did make that scene.
Beverly D'Angelo was the woman
selling the record collection,
but she got cut completely.
In fact, in the
movie, you can see
Rob talking to her on
the phone, but they never
use the actual scene.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
I remember him talking.
NICK HORNBY: It's on YouTube.
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Where everything is.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So
speaking of movies,
were you surprised
when people first
talked about making
your books into movies?
I guess "Fever
Pitch," obviously.
NICK HORNBY: Yes.
I was amazed.
At the beginning of a career,
I think everything is amazing,
because your first ambition
is to try and get published,
and your second
ambition is for somebody
to walk into a bookstore
and buy the book.
And amongst those two
things have been achieved,
you think well, that's it.
I now have got to
write the next one.
But it was amazing
to me that somebody
said they wanted to make a movie
of "Fever Pitch," which wasn't
a movie in there's
no story in the book.
It's a memoir, and
it covers 25 years,
and it's written in the
form of match reports.
And I wasn't
thinking in that way.
Also, the other thing
I was going to say
is being published in other
countries, which again never
occurred to me at all
when I started writing.
So "Fever Pitch"
was a big surprise,
and then "High Fidelity,"
a smaller surprise I guess,
because it had already
started to happen
with "Fever Pitch" at the time.
And then I got used to the idea
that actually, where I still
don't think most
people know this,
but more or less, any book
with a story and characters
in gets optioned at some
point in the film food chain.
And that might be a studio
who are willing to pay you
proper money for it, or it might
be a 22-year-old who's just
set up as an
independent producer
three doors down the street
on his computer saying,
will you give me the rights?
I promise you if anything ever
gets made, I'll see you right.
But the vast majority
of them don't get made,
and my great good fortune
is, so far, that most of them
seem to have been made.
MALE SPEAKER: Congratulations.
So going back even
further than that,
what drove you to be a
writer in the first place?
NICK HORNBY: Well, I guess
it's just one of those things
that I couldn't seem
to do anything about.
When young people ask me
for advice about writing,
the first thing I say is
if you can stop, stop.
That's the best advice.
And if you can't
stop, then tough.
You're a writer.
And that was pretty much my
situation that I couldn't stop,
and I didn't care how
many times I got rejected.
I would just start off
with the next thing
with an increasingly
heavy heart, obviously.
But I was doing that thing
where I had parted company
from my peers in terms of they
were on some kind of career
ladder, and I was drifting
in and out of work,
because I'd write something.
I started off trying
to write scripts.
I would write something
and get it rejected,
then go back to work,
and work for awhile,
and then get enough money
to leave work for awhile.
I have anxious parents
and anxious girlfriends,
and you just feel like you're
walking the plank, really,
that you can't go back,
because there's nothing back
there, so you've just
got to keep on going.
But it has always
felt like a need,
and it still feels like a need.
When I contemplate
retirement, I contemplate
writing really-- short
stories or something,
but it would be writing.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
So you started off writing
movie scripts or TV scripts?
NICK HORNBY: I don't know
what they were, actually.
I didn't know the
first thing about them.
They were probably somewhere
between BBC radio plays
and feature movies, but
really kind of indistinct.
We did have some-- we had a long
tradition throughout probably
the '60s and '70s of
one-hour plays on the BBC.
They don't make them anymore.
They're sort of one-off
things, and lots
of dramatists and
screenwriters cut their teeth
on those things.
And I was continuing
to write those long
after the BBC had
stopped making them.
I knew the BBC had
I don't know why I
wrote what I wrote.
That was just the right form.
But I think the thing
about writing movies
is that no one can take a
chance on you with a script.
The brilliant thing about
book writing and publishing
is that a publisher
can read a novel
and think, OK,
this is quite good.
And the second book might be
really good, and the third one,
we might begin to see
something on our investment.
And so you can give an
author not very much money
and print not very many books,
but you can nurture a career,
whereas with
screenplays, they cost
between five and $50 million,
and it doesn't matter
how much you believe
in someone's future,
you can't invest that sort
of money in the script.
And I think prose is easily the
best way to start as a writer,
if you can.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's
say we're compiling advice
to young would-be writers here.
Don't write, if you can--
NICK HORNBY: Don't write--
MALE SPEAKER:
--possibly not write.
NICK HORNBY: It's number one.
MALE SPEAKER: If you must write,
write prose, not screenplays.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
Or have the two things
on the go, at least.
I mean there are young
screenwriters who
become screenwriters, but
I think it's a hard route.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, definitely.
So in terms of your writing,
I find in both your nonfiction
and your fiction, there's sort
of a conversational quality
that comes across as, to me,
an effortlessness that almost
invariably means throughout
literature that the writer is
really sweat and
blood to achieve.
I come across that
countless times.
I'll admire somebody's
writing, and say, oh, they're
toying with us.
They just write so
easily, and you read,
well, I write three
sentences a day,
and I go back the next day,
and I cross everything out,
and rewrite them like Annie
Dillard, for instance.
How does your
writing process work?
I've read a little bit about
how you go to your workplace
or office, not far
from your house,
and you will write for
however many hours.
How much of that is
original writing?
How much is rewriting?
How much pain and torture
is involved, basically?
NICK HORNBY: My first drafts
tend to be in reasonable shape.
But the process of
getting to a first draft,
I can't stand leaving
something that I
know isn't right, so there
is a lot of rewriting
during the first draft,
if you show it to me,
and I can't just
splurge a first draft,
and then go back
and work it over.
I have to know that
paragraph by paragraph,
things are in reasonable
shape before I progress.
So there will be a lot of work
that goes into each paragraph,
and once I've got to
the end of a draft,
it's in a position where I
can turn it in and give it
to an editor and
work with an editor.
That thing of
writing 80,000 words
without looking at it just
to get it down on paper
doesn't happen for me.
It comes in little
bits and jerks
and really kind of annoying.
My writing process really
annoys me, and I don't like it,
but there isn't much
I can do about it.
I try and write between
500 and 1000 words a day,
which isn't that much.
Well, it doesn't feel like that
much, but if you do the maths,
this book is 100,000 words,
it should be 100 days' work.
It wasn't.
I can't account for
the rest of the time.
It's not a particularly
enjoyable process for me,
but I do want it to
be conversational.
I do want it to be
accessible, and that
does mean going through
some kind of digestive--
I'll stop with the metaphor,
but the conversational aspect
of it, yes, has worked.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, actually this paints
kind of a grim picture,
because I remember
from "Fever Pitch," one
of your first impressions going
with your father to matches
was how unhappy all
the people seemed.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So for a writer
who is unhappy with the process
to then go to relax at a
match, it sounds miserable.
NICK HORNBY: It all fits in.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sorry, your
life sounded terribly unhappy.
NICK HORNBY: It's all-- I mean
the thing about the football,
one of the things that impressed
me about it was how seriously
people took their fun, and
that's something that has been
important to me my entire
life, whether you're listening
seriously to music or reading
seriously or watching movies
seriously and writing
movies seriously.
The things that set
those people apart
are that they are willing to
take something, apparently
trivial, very, very
seriously, indeed,
and I always liked
those people the most.
MALE SPEAKER: No,
I can see that.
Just "High Fidelity,"
for instance.
NICK HORNBY: Exactly.
I think I don't trust people who
don't have some kind of passion
outside work or who have made
their passion their work.
MALE SPEAKER: I can
definitely see that.
NICK HORNBY: That's why I don't
like politicians, I think.
The only thing they seem
to be bothered about
is politics and not the
outside world of politics,
but the inside
world of politics.
They tend not to know a
great deal about anything
that I'm interested in.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
maybe in the UK.
In the US, our politicians are
incredibly well-rounded people
who are very well-informed
about everything.
I'm sorry about your
own politicians.
So you started off,
obviously, writing a memoir,
and then actually
moved to screenwriting
before writing novels.
Do you feel comfortable?
And obviously you've
written criticism
along the way, reviews.
Do you feel comfortable
moving back and forth
among the different forms?
Do you have to sort of,
oh, I finished this.
Now I'm going to go do my
monthly book review now.
Is it sort of a seamless
transition for you?
Do you have to sort
of catch your breath?
NICK HORNBY: Well, it's
a seamless transition
between fiction and
nonfiction and prose.
I don't find that
much of an issue.
The switch between screenwriting
and prose, I think, is hard,
and it takes awhile to adjust.
Not so much going
to screenwriting,
but going from
screenwriting to prose,
and I think there's something
about the brevity of the form
with screenwriting that can
damage prose a little bit,
because even though it's good
to be economical with words,
you still can't write 90 pages
with not much writing on them,
and hope that that's a novel.
It isn't.
You do have to expand and
think about the things
that people aren't seeing
or that they don't know,
and with screenwriting,
you can hope
that the actors and the
director and the set
designer and the art department
can provide the things
that you're not
including in your script,
but you have to do it all
yourself with fiction.
And I think it is
a jump back in.
I always seem to prefer the
one I'm not doing at the time.
That probably fits in with the
miserable football [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
More misery, I was just
going to say, more misery.
Sure.
So I'm also fascinated by the
book reviewing and the reading
part of that.
In addition to being a
prolific writer yourself,
you're obviously a
fairly voracious reader,
except when you're
not, and your reviews
have been collected
several times.
Do you consider
yourself a bibliophile,
or do you just love to read?
I mean, to me, there's
a slight distinction.
NICK HORNBY: A
bibliophile in the sense
of wanting to possess books?
Expensive books?
MALE SPEAKER: Any books.
I'm a bibliophile.
This is why I ask.
NICK HORNBY: I love the
object, and before I came here,
I was traveling around
the library at Harvard.
I had an invitation to go
and see some of their stuff,
and I mean, it's sort of
jaw-dropping what they've got
there, and I was looking at
Dickens's letter opener and his
walking stick and the notebook
that George Eliot used to make
notes for "Middlemarch," and
I didn't-- it was really cool
to see.
I didn't covet it,
and my book collection
is now a book
collection, but partly
because as you get
older, you realize
that books you bought 20
years ago when they came out
were, as it were,
first editions,
and you only read them once,
and you've kept them nicely.
Oh, and you went to see the
author read, and he signed it,
and that author's now dead.
And slowly, you
have a collection
that's worth something.
I went to see Raymond Carver
read on a Saturday afternoon
at a paperback bookshop
in the Fulham Road,
and it was so crappily
done that they didn't even
close the store.
Raymond Carver
was trying to read
above the sound of these
braying Chelsea women trying
to buy the new Jeffrey Archer
novel and saying, who's that?
Who's that over there?
But he signed my book.
Raymond Carver wrote, "To Nick.
Best wishes, Ray Carver."
And of course, I
kept it, and I don't
know if that makes
me a bibliophile.
Is that a bibliophile?
MALE SPEAKER: By some
definition, by some definition.
NICK HORNBY: Not in the sense
that I scour catalogs and bid
for items on eBay or
anything like that.
But I do love books
as objects, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
In terms of the
reading itself, I
know I've met some writers
who say, I'm writing a book.
I'm in the last six
weeks of a book.
I can't read anything else,
because I'll be too influenced
by this book style or the
narrative tone or whatever.
Do you find that
yourself, or can you
just read while you're writing?
NICK HORNBY: I think
those people-- well,
I won't be rude about them.
MALE SPEAKER: No, go ahead.
NICK HORNBY: I mean if I think
a novel, if I'm writing a novel,
and I pick up a
novel by somebody
who I think might be
tonally similar to me
or writing in a
similar narrative area,
then I won't touch it.
But given what's left, like the
whole of human literature, no.
Of course, I read.
I'm really conscious of how
many years I have left to me,
and I want to read as
much as I possibly can,
but I read a lot of nonfiction.
I read books about music.
I read books about sport.
I read books about books.
And none of these things
come into the process
of my own writing
while I'm writing.
My thing is off on
its own path by then,
and I couldn't bear
not to read, no.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
Compulsive [INAUDIBLE].
Love that.
And music, obviously, a
big part of your life.
It's actually hard to believe
your passion for football
has left room for another
equally big passion, which
obviously is music.
You've written for
"The New Yorker."
You've written 31 songs, which,
surprisingly, for some reason,
I'll say the following,
because just as an American,
I've always connected
the two of you
even though you've probably
never met John Peel.
He was unimpressed by 31
songs, I think, and only
because you're both such soccer,
or sorry-- football fanatics--
and you both love music.
I thought you must've been great
friends, although you probably
never even met.
NICK HORNBY: No.
I didn't meet him, actually, no.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
But anyway, John Peel aside,
you also write lyrics for songs.
You're a great supporter of
particular bands, apparently
one of the world's great experts
on mix tapes, making mix tapes.
What about music?
It's obviously played a
huge role in your life.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
Well, there's a great quote
by the critic, Walter Pater,
that said all art aspires
towards the condition of music.
And I do think it's the
most sophisticated form
of self-expression that somebody
who is able to express emotion
through music is really
getting the job done, I think,
because there's such
emotional precision in music
that you can't really hope
to match with words or paint
or anything else.
And when I write,
it's all the music
I love coming out in
word form, so music
goes in as some kind
of petrol, as gasoline,
and then comes out as
prose or a screenplay.
So it's a constant inspiration,
and the opposite to sport,
actually, because it
only makes me happy.
And if I'm listening
to sad music,
it's not by accident, whereas
if I'm made sad by football,
it's always by accident.
There's sport-- you
start with great hope,
and then you're destroyed
by the results of your team.
And the is only ever
pleasure, and, of course,
fits into so many parts of life.
Sport is once or twice a week
and endless conversations,
but music is when
I'm walking to work,
when I'm taking a
break from work,
when I'm sitting on a plane.
It comes into every area.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Do you listen to music
while you work, or do you--
NICK HORNBY: No.
Certainly not music with words.
I just find it too
busy, so it's-- no.
It tops me up in
between bits of writing.
MALE SPEAKER:
Pleasure in your life.
NICK HORNBY: Yes.
You found it.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's been
a long, raging debate in the US
about the merits of digital
music versus vinyl, which
is actually, in this
country at least,
in a renaissance among
younger fans and bands.
Has there been a similar
debate in the UK?
And if so, where do you stand
on this important question?
NICK HORNBY: Well,
I'm right on-- I
seem to be-- my life
seems to have exemplified
the argument in
that about a year
or so ago, I was-- I'm
not a purist about music.
Same with books.
I just want the
stuff, and I don't
mind what form it comes
in, and I love my iPod,
and I love my iPod Classic, and
I'm really sorry that the iPod
Classic's been discontinued,
but I was scrolling through it
and looking at
some of the stuff.
And I think, I don't know
who the hell this person is.
I don't know why
I downloaded it.
I don't know what it belongs to.
I'm going to play some of it.
Oh.
It's terrible.
I'm going to 5 seconds of it
and move onto the next thing.
And there was so much
of that in my life,
where I wasn't committed
to this person I
didn't know in the first place.
And especially if you work at
a computer all day on your own,
and no one's going to
spot what you're doing,
I spent a lot of time
surfing, finding new music,
downloading someone's
playlist that they've put on,
not listening to it, going
on for a bit more to download
someone else's, and
so on and so forth.
Anyway, I got to
the point where I
thought I'm going to
start buying vinyl again,
because you have
to go someplace.
You can't have turntables
all over your house.
There's one place in your house
where you have a turntable,
and you can't keep
skipping the tracks,
and I'm going to sit
down and listen to it.
At least give it that
much-- 20 minutes,
and pay some money for it.
Because I knew vinyl,
and it's not cheap.
It's like 20 pounds for
an album in England,
between 15 and 20 pounds.
To buy an album,
you have to think
about what it is you
want to listen to
at that kind of price.
And once you've
bought it, you give it
the courtesy of
some time, which I
wasn't doing with
digital music at all.
Set against that, in
the last two months,
I've become an
obsessive Spotify user,
because I didn't understand
properly what Spotify could be
or did.
And as a consequence,
I've been more
experimental with
my music, come out
of my comfort zone a lot
more, because I'm not
committed financially or going
to commit myself financially.
So I've kind of become more
educated through Spotify.
So I think my position
now is, I'm not
going to use iTunes anymore,
apart from what I've already
got.
It will be Spotify and
vinyl, and that's it.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Unlike you, I don't
have a good enough ear
to have a position one way
or the other, digital versus
vinyl.
NICK HORNBY: In terms of
the actual sound quality?
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe you do.
I don't know.
NICK HORNBY: I don't think I do.
I think I kid myself when I
listen to vinyl that I can hear
something that's richer,
and T Bone Burnett,
who I was talking
to recently, says
he's got it set up
in his studio that he
has a digital recording
and an analog recording
of the same piece of music.
And he says that when
he plays it to people,
they literally cannot
believe the difference.
They can't even believe
it's the same record.
But I don't have a
sound system where
it seems to me to make
a marked difference.
So it's not really
about the sound quality.
It's about the
commitment to the music.
MALE SPEAKER: I
have to say, for me,
there's something about
vinyl that I think Rob talks
about in the context of
making the perfect mix tape.
And to me on vinyl, that
specifically the transition
from the last song on side one
to the first song on side two.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: You know
what I'm talking about.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Because
the last long on side
one is usually a crescendo.
You're ending a side
pretty much with a bang.
The second song on side two--
sort of starting off very easy.
But I love that transition
from that one song
to the other, which we've
really lost with digital.
NICK HORNBY: Well, the thing
with them making playlists
is that you're not
listening to the music
as you're doing it, whereas
if you make a mix tape,
there wasn't on analog,
with vinyl to cassette type,
there wasn't anything to be
done while you were doing it
apart from listening
to the song.
And of course, while you're
spending three or four
minutes listening to a
song, then you're thinking,
oh, that guitar solo
sounds like that,
or this lyric
reminds me of that.
And so while you're
listening to the song,
it gives you maybe
four or five choices
for the next song, which
are more considered choices,
whereas if you're doing a
playlist here-- blip, blip,
blip, blip, blip-- you haven't
got any of the sound of that.
You can remember the record, but
you haven't got the actual feel
or sound in your head
while you're doing it.
So I think, by definition,
they have to be inferior.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
No.
I totally agree.
I still have dozens
of mix tapes at home
that other people made
for me or that I made.
So I honestly wish we
could talk for hours,
but we can't, and you're here to
talk about "Funny Girl," which
I think is just been
published today?
NICK HORNBY: It's today, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: First
ones to get it.
I turn it over to
you and the book.
What should your fans
know about this book?
What do you want to
tell us about it?
NICK HORNBY: Well,
I mean it really
comes from having spent a
lot of the last three or four
years writing for screen, and
after "An Education," I also
adapted Colm Toibin's
"Brooklyn," and it got stuck,
and then unstuck, and then the
funding collapsed, and then
a director left, and then a
director came, and it's just
the normal process of film.
And it showed at
Sundance last week,
finally, after
four or five years.
And I write a series
for HBO, which
is they commissioned a pilot.
Then they didn't
commission the series,
and I wrote "Wild"
for Reese Witherspoon,
and that got made
really quickly.
And they were two things
about all these experiences.
One, the experience of
working collaboratively
with really smart,
clever people, and two,
the frustrations when
it doesn't get anywhere.
And the big thing
about screenwriting
is that you need
permission all the time.
We were talking about
the money before,
but there were about
25 gatekeepers.
So you write a script,
and you need a cast for it
to be a movie.
You need a director.
You need money.
You need an editor.
You need this, this, this, this.
And your work, your script
is not a finished thing.
Your script is a script.
That's all it is.
It's not a movie.
And you can't give it to
someone and say, read my script,
unless they're used to the
idea of reading scripts,
whereas with a novel, if you
have finished it, it's a novel.
It doesn't matter if
nobody publishes it.
It doesn't matter if nobody
buys it in a bookstore.
It is a novel.
It's its own thing.
Anyway, I wanted to write
about the experience of working
collaboratively, and I wanted
to write about in novel form,
because I was sick of
all the permissions
and the gatekeepers.
So this novel is about
the birth, life, and death
of a fictional sitcom, and
it's about clever people
working at the top of their
game and having fun and being
unable to stay there, because
no band or collaborative
team can ever stay
permanently wedded forever,
even though when we love their
work, we wish they could.
So it's about the funny
girl, and the title
is the star of this
sitcom and her costar
and the two writers
and the producer.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
NICK HORNBY: And it's
set in the 1960s,
because I wanted to write
about the characters old now
at the end.
MALE SPEAKER: And possibly
inspired by Lucille Ball,
I've read.
NICK HORNBY: Yeah.
Well, the character is
inspired by Lucille Ball.
The novel, not particularly.
But she wanted-- this
character wants to be funny,
and she doesn't have
any other role models.
It was quite strange
about England
that our comedy actually
was so masculine.
If you look at something
like "Monty Python,"
there were no women
apart from some women
who ran around in bikinis
at strategic points
in the program.
And we had "Steptoe
and Son" which
became "Sanford
and Son," two men.
And we had a program called
"The Likely Lads," which
was two men, and it was
very male-dominated.
So there's an element of sort
of alternative reality in this
that it's a female
comedienne at that time.
MALE SPEAKER: And would you like
to read something from it, or--
NICK HORNBY: Sure.
I'm going to read
about the two writers.
"Tony Holmes and
Bill Gardner met
in a holding cell in a
police station in Aldershot
the week before
Christmas in 1959.
The local police wanted
the military police
to take them back
to the barracks.
The military police didn't
want anything to do with them.
While the two sets of
authorities wrangled,
they sat there for 24
hours talking, smoking,
and not sleeping, both of them
feeling stupid and very afraid.
They ascertained that
they'd both in arrested
in the same place in the
same street two hours apart.
They didn't even tell each other
what they'd been doing wrong
or where precisely
they'd been doing it.
They didn't need to.
They just knew.
Neither of them had ever been
caught back at home in London,
but for different reasons.
Bill hadn't been caught,
because he was smart
and knew the places to go,
the clubs and the bars,
and even the public
conveniences,
although he didn't
use them very often.
The evening's events
had reminded him why.
The policeman who'd
arrested him in Aldershot
may well have been an
agent provocateur, one
of those officers who
hated his kind with such
a peculiar and obsessive
passion that they were prepared
to spend entire evenings
trying to catch them.
There were plenty of
them in London too.
Tony had never been
caught in London,
because he'd never tried
anything in London,
or anywhere else
for that matter.
He wasn't sure about
a lots of things,
including who and
what he was, but he
had no clear idea why he
decided to try and find
the answers to these
questions right
before the end of
his national service.
Loneliness, certainly,
and boredom,
and the sudden desperate
need for the touch
of a fellow human being of
any gender, though admittedly,
he was only likely to
find one of the two
in the gents' toilets
in Tennyson Street.
In the end, nobody had the
stomach to prosecute them,
and the following day, they
returned to the barracks
to complete the rest of
their national service.
Whenever they looked back
on that evening, which
they did frequently,
although never together
and never out loud,
there wasn't much
that they recognized about the
circumstances of their arrest.
Had they really been
desperate enough
to get so near to humiliation
and possible ruin?
But the contents of their
24-hour conversation
stayed reassuring and
familiar, even years later.
They talked about comedy.
They discovered
their mutual passion
for Ray Galton and Alan Simpson
within minutes of meeting.
They could quote whole
chunks of Hancock's Half Hour
to each other, and they tried to
remember as much as they could
of "The Blood Donor" so
that they could perform it.
They were pretty sure they were
word perfect on the hospital
scene, with Bill playing Hancock
and Tony with the higher,
more nasal voice taking
on the Hugh Lloyd part.
They kept in touch when
they were demobbed.
Tony lived in East London and
then Bill was up in Barnet,
so they used to meet in
town in a Soho coffee bar
once a week, at first, when
they were both still working
in the jobs they were
trying to escape.
Tony was helping his father
in the news agency he owned.
Bill was a pen pusher at
the Department of Transport.
They spent the first
few months talking,
and then eventually
overcame their embarrassment
and started trying to write
together on two notepads.
Later, when they took the
leap into unemployment,
they met every day in
the same coffee bar
and would continue
to do so until they
could afford an office.
They never talked about the
other thing they may or may not
have had in common,
but Bill was still
shocked when Tony got married.
He'd never even
mentioned seeing someone.
Bill went to the wedding,
and Tony's bride,
a sweet, quiet, clever
brunette called June
who worked at the
BBC, seemed to know
all about her
husband's partners,
or as much as she would
have wanted to know anyway.
And maybe there wasn't
anything else to find out.
Bill and Tony wrote
comedy scripts together.
That was who they were, and
Aldershot Police Station
had nothing to do
with anything."
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I should point out
that homosexuality
was illegal in
England until 1967,
and quite a few people
were imprisoned.
And the other thing is I came
up with that idea, which,
of course, obviously has a big
influence on the characters,
their sexuality,
because the two writers
that they talk about--
Galton and Simpson
that they admire who did
write "Steptoe and Son," which
was "Sanford and Son," and all
of these great English comedy
programs-- these two guys
met in real life in a TB
clinic, tuberculosis clinic in
London at the end of the war.
And a lot of people, young
people, especially in London,
contracted tuberculosis because
of the state of sanitation.
And in fact, one of
them, in particular,
was seriously ill and
had the last rites read
and all that sort of
thing, but as I was saying,
very beautiful story
that these two guys
in such unpromising
circumstances
when they were so ill, and
stayed together writing.
They still write together now.
And they still-- they
wrote to me about the book,
and they still sign
their letters together.
And they were a big
influence on my own writing
when I was growing up.
I think they're geniuses, and
I wanted some kind of homage
to them, which hence the
meeting in the prison.
But then it became a book
about their sexuality as well.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That's extraordinary.
Thank you.
Any questions for Nick
from the audience?
NICK HORNBY: Hi.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
brevity of screenwriting
and the fact that
that made it difficult
for you to write prose.
There's been, of course,
a lot of discussion
about the effects
of email and texting
and so on on the
writing abilities
of the general public.
What I'm wondering is,
have you seen any effects
on writings style of
professional writers?
Have electronic
media had effects
on the way literature
is written?
NICK HORNBY: That's a
very interesting question.
I can remember in
the late '80s, I
can remember some very
sniffy book critics saying,
oh, this is a word
processor novel.
And I never quite understood
what a word processor
novel was supposed to be, apart
from that people were using
more cut up forms,
and they thought
they could see evidence
of cutting and pasting
in this fiction.
But of course, that
was something else
going on in the culture.
It wasn't anything to do with
the means by which people
were using.
I was so grateful for a word
processor when I first got one.
It made me a better writer,
because I was such a bad typist
that if I saw a bad sentence
in the middle of a page,
I'd think, I'm not bloody
writing that whole thing out
again, whereas now, of course,
it's done in two seconds.
There have been lots
of novels recently
that have used email
and text, and yeah, I
think everything
is affecting us.
I think that this generation of
writers, the last two or three
generations, is the first
that grew up entirely
within popular culture, and I
think that makes a difference.
I haven't had a
classical education,
and my references
are-- my influences
are as much movies and
TV as they were books.
And I think that the
younger writers now
are very used to
writing quickly and not
caring so much about style.
And I think that as
it goes on, style
might well be not
what we think it is.
There is a kind of
classical prose style
that somebody like Henry
James or Somerset Maugham
or PG Woodhouse, these
people who crafted sentences,
I suspect that that will go
over the next 20 to 30 years.
And, of course, we will
miss some things about it,
but it will bring
other things too.
There's no doubt to
me that prose style
will be profoundly affected
by texting and emailing.
And I'm not saying
that as a nostalgic.
I think it's just inevitable.
MALE SPEAKER: I did want to talk
about your philanthropy work
a little bit.
NICK HORNBY: Charity rather
than philanthropy, I think.
I would like to be
a philanthropist,
but I'm not sure I'm
quite in that position.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
ambitious about autism
and the Treehouse School
and the Ministry of Stories.
Probably most people aren't
aware of your involvement
with those two causes.
NICK HORNBY: Well, my eldest
son has autism, and he's 21 now,
but when he was
three, four years old,
we couldn't find the
education that we wanted
for him or the
style of education.
There was something
going on in America
that wasn't available in the
UK, and we banded together
with another small group of
parents, four or five of us,
to form a school.
And we started with
these five autistic kids
in the local library, which
should be a proverb, I think,
to replace bull
in a China shop--
autistic kids in a library.
And eventually and slowly,
we got money together,
and I edited a book, which was
published here and in the UK
called "Speaking with the
Angel," which was a fundraiser.
And anyway, years went by,
and not just because of me
by any means, but eventually
this amazing school got built.
And it cost 12 million pounds,
and there are 90 kids there,
and it will be there forever.
And Danny's left there now.
So I moved on to something else
to do with my charitable time,
which was the Ministry of
Stories, which is exactly
Dave Eggers' 826 model.
The 826 schools--
you have an 826
in Boston, which I
hope you all support.
And whenever I went
to San Francisco,
I went to 826
Valencia, which always
has seemed to be the
most incredible place
creatively, all these
things going on,
Dave's running
McSweeney's from there,
and there were all
these young writers,
editors making magazines.
"The Believer" was there.
McSweeney's was there,
t-shirts, and then
all these inner city kids
who were getting help off
all the people who were hanging
out at McSweeney's and getting
help with their writing.
And that seemed
to be such a kind
of perfect model of putting two
sections of society together--
one group of inner city
kids who weren't getting
the same opportunities
as everyone
else together with all these
kind of whiz kid graduate
people who were making
all these great magazines.
And they were-- one lot
was mentoring the other,
but I think everyone felt
good about the experience,
and then there was an 826 in
LA and in Boston and Chicago.
There's, I think, nine of
them across America now.
And I wanted to
do the same, so I
was introduced to two
people who were determined
to make it happen,
and I'm the co-founder
of this writing
school in East London.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
That's wonderful.
NICK HORNBY: It's such
a kind of no-brainer,
actually, to help kids with
their literacy, I think.
It's finding the ways
in which it works,
and I think this is
a model that works.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
Anything else for Nick?
Well, if not, thank you
very much for coming.
Thank you most of all
to Nick for joining us.
NICK HORNBY: Pleasure.